hey what's up guys my name is Jonah
welcome to episode 5 of network chat
programming so today we're going to talk
about actually making a window for our
client ok so what we've got right now is
a login window and that's all great and
we've actually made a way to pass
information into our client right so our
name address and port so that our client
can then connect to a server as well as
give ourselves a name and that's all
cool but now we're going to actually
talk about making that window where
people can you know chat and receive
messages and all that stuff as well as
actually connect to a server so let's um
let's get right into that but first what
I want to do is actually fix a little
little problem here in episode 2 we
wrote a UI manager thing that things
kind of disappeared and it never got
committed to github because of a vast
array of issues so I just want to set
the look and feel to you why manager dot
get system look and feel class name
alright and you might remember we did do
this in episode 2 so if you follow the
videos this would have been sort of been
done but unfortunately it didn't carry
across through the commits okay so we'll
just change this to exception like we
did in episode 2 this just basically
makes it look like your systems native
window so just makes it look native and
I do explain that in more detail in
episode 2 as it should so check that out
if you haven't
but anyway so let's create that new
window now so to make a new window right
right now if I just go to design and
wait for it to pass as usual um yep
you'll see a little window here and if I
actually debug or on the application you
can see that we've got all this stuff
here we can enter and when we hit login
the idea is obviously to hide this like
we do right now and more or less
actually open that window right and what
one thing which probably do is also
handle if the ports are black if if the
filter blank for example will do that
later
ok so let's make a new window so right
click on to our channel chat folder here
in the navigator or in the package
Explorer hit new and hit other
and then go down here to je frames is on
the window builder swing designer in the
jframe get next let's call it a client
and let's hit finish all right so it's
still our code first thing you should
probably realize is let's get rid of
these Java Docs Java dot comments first
thing you should probably realizes we
don't need a main method right because
we're not launching this as a separate
application we're just opening this
window based on our main application
which is our login to Java okay so we
can just get rid of this completely
before we do you might you might notice
the frameless have visible true is
actually set over here so let's quickly
move that into here so that we can
actually see our frame and then let's
get rid of this entirely and I'll just
add a default version Heidi and I think
that's it it's pretty much it okay so if
we hit the design button you'll see this
window now will probably resize it to
let's say maybe around 800 wide yeah
let's set it to about um if you go over
here by the way if you click on this if
you go over here there is a um size or
is there can't see it am I being stupid
no what has it there's no size yeah okay
I can't say that here anyway let's go
back to the source code let's get rid of
this set bounds like we had last time
and let's probably just set the location
relative to null to Center it and let's
set these size to be probably be out 800
by 480 or so I don't know we'll see what
that looks like I think that's pretty
good though might be a bit too wide I
might set it to around 750 or something
750 I don't know
okay so now we've got this this is all
this is all really good now okay we've
got a new window that we can actually
open so over here into logins or Java
all I want to add is instead of printing
this stuff I basically want to make a
new client right and into that client I
actually want to feed in the name
the address and the port okay so over
here in client let's make a few things
let's make some more fields so it will
make two strings called name and address
and we'll make an integer called port
right and we'll put string name string
address and import into here and then
the first thing that we'll do is set
this name equal to name this dot address
equal to address and this dot port
equal to port again so what I mean here
is obviously setting all of our
parameters here equal to our global
variable so that they can be accessed
throughout our entire client class one
thing I like to do is we'll probably
make a create window method here um and
just copy all of this code or cut all
this code into here just so that our
constructor looks a bit cleaner and
obviously actually run the create window
method here create window okay as you
can see that kind of just clears
everything up and more or less what
we'll do is actually use these things to
connects so we'll have to make of work
obviously have to write a bunch of
network code to get it to connect to our
server which we haven't made a server
yet so that could be interesting but
anyway the point is what should happen
now is we dispose of this window we make
a new window which is a client window
and everything is cool so let's test it
out really quickly I just pop in like
open airy on localhost I have one line
to whatever hit login and as you can see
our whole windows disappears and our new
window pops up it's probably bit too
small actually I'm not sure let's make
it a bit bigger but yeah you can see
that basically that works so mate I
might make it 800 and maybe about 550 or
something I don't know
and two more things I want to do here
quickly
are set the title to something cool so
let's set it to Cherno chat client just
that appears there you can see and let's
also add a layout too and now we're
going to talk about layouts more in
next times I've broken up into there
right now but we will be using a grid
back layout which is right over here
and that's just basically to ensure that
we can resize our window and older
components move along with that so we'll
talk about layouts and the grid bag
layout next time when episode six and in
Episode seven we'll probably start on
the actual sockets and sending data to a
server but yeah so if we launch our
thing right now I'm just going to type
in a number into here so it doesn't
crash hit login and as you can see
channel check on this is hey that sighs
okay that's why I think this bigger
we're changing this 8:50 okay that's
probably almost good at 80 okay I like
that
okay so yeah so what you can see if it's
happening here is we can we can enter a
bunch of information into these things
and number into here hit login and our
old windows our old window disappears
our login window and hnh r''h client
window appears which is going to be our
actual check line okay so that is how
that works and I hope you enjoyed this
episode of network chat programming and
I'll see you guys tomorrow with a new
episode later guys
you